l' aventure scientifique en vidéo c'est
ait un challenger
s'envoler quand bon vous semble pour
l'un des six nations que leur exigent
leur confort ouaté d'avion de rêve c'est
entrer dans un autre monde celui des
avions d'affaires
le monde prestigieux des falcons les
falcons les avions des rois et des
présidents sont surtout aujourd'hui ceux
des sociétés et des hommes d'affaires
soucieux d'économiser le temps qui passe
mais également ceux des forces aériennes
désireuse de conserver leur indépendance
et d'évoluer librement par delà les mers
et les océans
les falcons une véritable famille
d'avions de légende
longtemps considérés comme de simples
palaces volants sont devenues désormais
autant de vecteurs allié fidèle et
irremplaçable des décideurs de cette fin
du xxème siècle
les falcons séounes 100 avions tous
types confondus représentant 16% des
7000 avions d'affaires volant
aujourd'hui dans le monde
une fabuleuse aventure de plus de 30 ans
aux couleurs de la haute technologie
européenne
appelés à l'origine mystère 20 le nouvel
avion mais en 1961 dans les bureaux
d'études de dassault fait appel à des
solutions technique déjà éprouvée sur
d'autres appareils conçus par la société
des avions militaires notamment comme le
mystère 4a dont il hérite de la
définition générale et de la voilure et
le super mystère b2 pour les méthodes
d'assemblage
le 4 mai 1963 à bordeaux mérignac c'est
le premier vol historique du prototype
du mystère 20 piloté par rené bigand
on le voit c'est comme pour la caravelle
la position en nacelle latérales arrière
qui a été finalement retenue pour les
moteurs de ce biréacteur capable de
transporter 10 passagers à 800 km heure
sur plus de 3000 km un avion français
qui intéresse dès l'origine au plus haut
point les américains et notamment la
panam qui souhaitent se lancer dans la
distribution d'avions d'affaires
le jour même du premier vol une
délégation du transporteur américain
conduite par le célèbre aviateur charles
lindbergh se fait présenter le prototype
et après deux mois de pourparlers
c'est la commande ferme de 40 avions et
la prise en option de 120 autres
rapidement le centième avions et
construit des avions qui reçoivent par
la panam le nom de baptême de femmes
jets falcon puis tout simplement de
falcon pas pour honorer les commandes
aux usines dassault de bordeaux-mérignac
comme à celle de sud aviation à saint
nazaire les chaînes tournent à plein
régime et on dépassera même la cadence
de cet avion construit par mois à la fin
des années 60 avec l'arrivée sur le
marché de petits réacteurs moins
gourmands en carburant
c'est la naissance du ministère vin le
plus rapide de la famille très vite
appelé falcon 10 construit en
coopération avec l'espagne l'italie et
plusieurs industriels français le falcon
10 avant même son premier vol sera son
tour commandé à 40 exemplaires par la
panam
il deviendra plus tard falcon sans le
premier avion d'affaires du monde
certifié avec une planche de bord
équipés de tubes cathodiques couleurs
devant le succès rencontré des versions
dérivées du falcon 20 comme le falcon 30
sont étudiés il est conçu pour
transporter 30 passagers sur des lignes
commerciales secondaire mais à cause de
la crise pétrolière a prévu de 73 74 qui
frappe notamment de plein fouet le
transport aérien mondial
le projet est abandonné l'engouement de
la clientèle américaine pour les falcons
peut s'expliquer en partie par la
conception même il y a plus de 30 ans de
ce nouveau type de transport l'avion
pour les décideurs un bureau volant un
espace affaires plutôt qu'un avion de
tourisme ultra rapide
le falcon 10 et sa version modernisée le
falcon sens seront vendus à 226
exemplaires répartis entre 20 pays à
travers le monde
le falcon sens comme le falcon 20 à la
robustesse légendaire connaît
aujourd'hui encore l'absence de
limitation du nombre et des heures de
vol permise les services officiels
américains ayant autorisé la
prolongation de la durée de vie de la
cellule jusqu'à 60 mille heures de vol
c'est ta vie avec aujourd'hui environ
seulement 30% de leur potentiel utiliser
les falcons les bienheureux ont une
espérance de vie bien au delà de l'an
la solidité de la structure des falcons
permet à la fin des années 70 de
moderniser les deux premiers membres de
la famille le 10 devient falcon sens et
le vin falcone 201 avions roues
motorisés par l'américain garrett avec
comme conséquence l'augmentation de 50 %
de la distance franchissable par
l'appareil et le respect des normes de
bruit de plus en plus draconiennes
un avion aux performances techniques
remarquables grâce à une structure une
aérodynamique et des systèmes
entièrement nouveau
le 200 peut transporter huit à dix
passagers sur des étapes de plus de 4000
km
à
une gamme d'avions qui toutes versions
confondues 20 et 200 sera vendu dans le
monde entier à plus de 500 exemplaires
20 comme 200 vont bénéficier pour
l'élaboration des différents éléments
constitutifs de l'avion comme pour son
assemblage à bordeaux-mérignac de toute
la haute technologie dérivée directement
de l'acquis de dassault en matière
militaire
etc
autre élément essentiel comme pour ces
familles d'avions de combat ouragans
mystère et mirage le constructeur
français avec les falcons reste fidèle à
sa politique d'évolution technique
mesuré pas de révolution technologique
entre deux avions
mais l'intégration de solutions
technique déjà éprouvée sur d'autres
appareils
une fiabilité et une disponibilité
remarquable qui fait que la marine
française pour la surveillance maritime
du pacifique
et comme on va le voir les causes
guard's les gardes-côtes américains
utilisent aujourd'hui quotidiennement
leur falcone autre atout technologique
200 une avionique de pointe
constitué d'une visualisation catholique
couleurs la réussite commerciale que
connaît depuis plus de 30 ans la famille
falcon elle la doit au formidable
engouement de la mairie pour ce nouveau
concept d'avion et notamment de la panam
mais aussi à la confiance de clients
célèbres comme les coast guard est le
spécialiste américain du transport
express de fret fédéral express
doté aujourd'hui d'une véritable flotte
aérienne de plus de 460 avions allant du
csna au boeing 747 fédéral express
utilise à l'origine dans les années 70
33 falcon 20 spécialement équipées de
portes cargo pour transporter en express
le fret aérien
une véritable armada d'avions sollicité
quotidiennement fedex s'est aujourd'hui
1 million 700 mille colis soit environ
6000 tonnes transportées chaque jour
entre 178 pays de la planète
ces 33 falcon aux couleurs de fedex même
s'ils ne sont plus utilisés aujourd'hui
auront contribué même modestement leur
temps à faire le succès de cette
entreprise américaine très performante
outre falcon multirôle aux couleurs des
états unis ceux des causses guard's les
garde-côtes américains
en tout quarante et un falcon va j'ai
baptisé h 25 guardian
une version particulièrement adaptée à
la recherche et au sauvetage en mer à la
surveillance maritime à moyenne distance
ou à des missions spécifiques comme la
lutte contre la pollution ou les
opérations antidrogue
les guardian ce américains ont été
utilisées avec succès en 91 pendant la
guerre du golfe notamment pour repérer
l'évolution des nappes de pétrole le
long des côtes du koweït et de l'arabie
saoudite
ce ne sont que deux exemples de
l'extraordinaire capacité les falcons
mise en uniforme à s'adapter à des
missions multi rôle des missions très
variées et autres que le transport de
passagers
autre application des multiples
possibilités d'utilisation des falcons
la photographie aérienne avec ici le
falcon 22 l'hygiène institut
géographique national français la
technique du recueil des données par
prises de vue aériennes consiste à
prendre en deux points différents deux
photos du même objet ou de la même
portion de terrain ainsi grâce à l'effet
stéréoscopique
on détermine la forme et la dimension de
l'objet photographié
après traitement ces données peuvent
être exploitées graphiquement ce sont
les cartes nous transformer en chiffres
c'est le traitement numérique des images
après correction ces images venues du
ciel est traité par ordinateur sont
numérisés c'est à dire transformer en
une multitude de chiffres constituant
ainsi une véritable banque de données
utilisées via des logiciels spécialisés
cette banque de données de l'igpn va
permettre de réaliser une foule
d'applications résolument high tech
premier exemple ici près de modane dans
les alpes françaises avec la réalisation
d'une photo carte pour l'aménagement de
la station de val fréjus
l'ortho photos en vue général combine
images végétation relief construction et
cartes topographiques un document
technique qui permet à moindre coût de
réaliser une étude de faisabilité les
travaux envisagés
deuxième exemple ici à lyon un autre
produit gêne un système de données
entièrement localisée fait d'un réseau
de points pris tous les 300 mètres
déterminer avec la précision du
millimètre et cela sur tous les
itinéraires principaux de la ville une
banque de données qui sera bientôt
alimentés par des images numériques
enfin à bry sur marne en région
parisienne la mise au point d'une base
de données des images en trois
dimensions
le résultat a tracé automatique de
perspectives urbaines vraiment étonnant
un procédé révolutionnaire qui permet de
visualiser et de simuler un projet
nouveau en la tuant ou en lui faisant
remplacer le tissu urbain existant
réalité ou simulation dans ces
magnifiques images venues du ciel
tout comme dans celle des salons
intérieur des falcons où il est
difficile de discerner la but réel de
celle créée par l'artiste
tout comme le falcon 10 avait été conçu
pour contenter les clients recherchant
la viande à faire plus petit et plus
économique que le falcon 20 le falcon 50
sél reste lui à ceux qui veulent en
toute sécurité traverser l'atlantique où
les états unis sans perdre le temps
d'une escale
premier avion d'affaires tri-réacteur au
monde le falcon 50 est également le
premier triréacteur de la famille
il est capable de transporter jusqu'à 14
passagers sur des distances pouvant
atteindre 6500 km c'est le premier
falcon au long cours le 50 et le premier
entièrement conçu en trois dimensions
sur ordinateur et le premier également à
utiliser les matériaux composites avec
notamment le carbone pour ses ailerons
une voilure révolutionnaire à profil
supercritique permettant une légère
augmentation de la vitesse de croisière
une sérieuse économie de carburant et
une augmentation de la capacité de ses
réservoirs
le falcon 50
le roi des avions l'avion des présidents
comme vantait la pub d'alors pour le
falcon 20 est avec ses trois réacteurs
fait pour l'atlantique nord un beau
succès commercial avec 230 avions vendu
à 160 clients
le falcon 900 c'est l'enfant de katia le
logiciel de conception et de fabrication
assistée par ordinateur développé par
dassault systèmes qui a permis de créer
de mettre au point et de fabriquer avec
une extrême précision ses formes
aérodynamiques et ses structures
directement dérivée du 50 on retrouve
dans le falcon 900 tous les acquis de
l'autre triréacteur de la famille auquel
vient s'ajouter toute une série de
technologies avancées comme une
avionique entièrement numérique des
matériaux composites entrant pour la
première fois dans la composition de la
structure de l'avion des pneus à
carcasse radiale et des francs carbone
c'est ce tri réacteur intercontinental
qui en 1984 fait son premier vol sur la
piste de bordeaux mérignac dans le sud
ouest de la france
le 900 et le premier avions à fuselage
large de la famille qui permettent aux
passagers de se tenir debout
quatorze places en configuration v ip et
jusqu'à 10,9 au maximum re motorisés en
version 900 b il peut dès le début de la
croisière atteindre 13 mm et donc évolué
mais directement au dessus du plus gros
du trafic 1
oh
autre atout son rayon d'action qui fait
du 900 b un transatlantique confortable
avec une distance franchissable de 7400
km avec huit passagers à bord et à
l'arrivée les réserves réglementaires de
carburant
le falcon 900 c'est le haut de gamme des
sept membres de la famille tant au
niveau du confort que de ses
performances
le 900 qui mêle america un seul modèle
de l'europe a d'ores et déjà été acheté
à plus de 120 exemplaires par une
centaine de clients dans le monde des
clients en général très discret qui
s'intéressent le plus souvent à ce type
d'oiseau drass pour l'efficacité et la
disponibilité qu'il procure que pour le
confort et le luxe qu'ils dispensent
il
lui
à
on
compromis entre les qualités
d'exploitation du 50 et le confort du
900 le falcon 2000 après deux ans
d'études de marché vient au monde
totalement enfanté par katia suit alors
un véritable ballet soigneusement régler
de l'ensemble des outils industriels
créer pour amener à maturité
le jeune prodige moins d'un an après
avoir décidé de lancer ce programme en
coopération entre dassault aviation et
l'industriel italien allait bien
les premiers tronçons de l'avion sont
prêts en france comme en italie le
tronçon avant est assemblé à
bordeaux-mérignac l'arrière à turin et
priorité est donnée à la réduction des
coûts de production pour le 2000 il n'y
aura pas de maquette même cet avion
numéro un sera commercialisé le falcon
2000 à large fuselage comme 900 est un
biréacteur transcontinental cost cost
comme disent les américains même outil
mêmes compétences mêmes méthodes chez
dassault comme ici chez alenia qui a
sous sa seule responsabilité toute la
partie arrière de l'avion
à martignas près de bordeaux l'ensemble
du fuselage et assemblés avant d'être
vérifiées et peser à mérignac
il sera alors prêt à recevoir sa voilure
puis c'est l'assemblée générale des
différents composants de l'avion les
ailes l'empennage les moteurs le train
d'atterrissage
pendant ce temps là aux états unis les
nouveaux réacteurs general electric
garrett cf 738 son tour à tour tester au
sol puis essayer en vol accolé au
fuselage d'un boeing
à
dans les soutes les planches et les
ailes de l'avion des kilomètres de
câbles des centaines de mètres de
tuyauterie en tous genres et de tous
diamètre électricité conditionnement
d'air hydraulique vont alors trouvé avec
précision leur place là encore grâce aux
logiciels de conception et de
fabrication katia puis bientôt ce sera
l'heure de l'aménagement commercial
laissant peu à peu deviner le cadre de
vie des futurs passagers
côté équipage aménagement du poste de
pilotage et de son avionique numérique
côté passagers des moyens de
communications par satellites les plus
modernes
suivent ensuite toute une série d'essais
statiques et de tests de vibration
et c'est des commandes de vol des volets
des becs et du train d'atterrissage
mise en place de l'aménagement intérieur
le falcon 2000s désormais prêt pour sa
première sortie hors du hangar qui l'a
vu naître et ses moteurs point fixe
réglages mise au point finale
l'avion peut être maintenant remis à
l'équipe des essais en vol mais reste
avant cela à le présenter à la
communauté aéronautique internationale
sur les fonts baptismaux de l'usiné de
mérignac transformé pour l'occasion en
palais des mille et unes
non
m
on
le falcon 2000 c'est le dernier né de la
prestigieuse famille d'avions d'affaires
un avion de nouvelle génération un
nouveau standard pour la fin du xxème
siècle un jet capable de réaliser de
longues étapes à haute altitude
événements ainsi en toute liberté au
dessus du trafic commercial de plus en
plus dense à une vitesse de croisière
élevée dans un environnement de confort
propice aux affaires ou au repos
et tout cela dans des conditions
économiques d'achat et d'exploitation
acceptable réaliser toutes ses
performances c'est le fantastique paris
du 2000 le premier falcon qui
officiellement à un prix un peu moins de
14 millions de dollars soit environ 80
millions de francs
les falcons une fabuleuse aventure
contribuant au renouveau des ailes de
l'europe avec plus de 90% des avions
vendu à l'exportation dans 70 pays
mon premier rang des acheteurs les états
unis avec environ 2 falcon sur trois les
falcons un véritable challenge pour la
haute technologie européenne